à
francfort où l'on vous dit aujourd'hui
qu'avant hitler un allemand sur dix
étaient juifs se déroule en ce moment le
procès dao schmitt
presque 20 ans après avoir cessé après
avoir dû cesser d' humilier de torture
et de tuer les accusés ont répondu à
l'appel du président
[Musique]
depuis le début de ce procès les accusés
ont deux vendeuses les plans des camps
d'extermination d'auschwitz birkenau
mais pour eux ces plans sont comme la
carte d'un pays qui n'aurait jamais
existé
ces camps de mort il en y l'existence
insolemment
ils n'ont jamais vu une arrivée le
convoi et quand on leur parle de
sélection ils ne comprennent pas ayant
oublié qu'il choisissait sur le quai
même d'arriver sur la rend ce qui
pouvait servir encore et ce qui devait
mourir sans délai dans la chambre à gaz
et chambres à gaz ne savent pas distille
qu'elle existait il faut crématoire non
plus
[Musique]
joe
morneau a chez moi
[Musique]
enfants
j'aime
[Musique]
et pourtant ces accusés il y en a 22
étaient des hommes horriblement
important à auschwitz
où lca qui n'a jamais entendu parler de
chambres à gaz étaient l'adjoint du
commandant du camp et la fenêtre de son
bureau donnait sur un crématoire
vos guerres tortionnaires membres de la
gestapo du camp section politique un
officier polonais est venu lui rappeler
qu'un matin il avait tué six enfants en
les prenant par les pieds et en les
frappant contre un mur car c'est ainsi
que l'accusation doit procéder
de crime en crime en épelant les crimes
l'infirmier clair ses mains étaient
mortels l'accusation estime qu'il a tué
vingt mille personnes par piqûre de
phénol son inconscience est grande à un
ancien déporté qui l'accablait monsieur
langman clair a dit je sais bien que
vous ne m'aimez pas déjà à auschwitz
vous n'aviez pas de sympathie pour moi
tous ont été surpris par cette justice
tardive qui pourrait à ce visage celui
du procureur coupes claires qui
prononcera contre le réquisitoire final
votre jeunesse monsieur le procureur
surprend quel âge avez vous
vous avez donc fait la guerre
n'avez-vous jamais eu la tentation
d'être nazi oui j'étais un membre de la
jeunesse citoyenne quand j'étais très
jeune
de combien de pages se compose l'acte
d'accusation l'acte d'accusation se
compose de sept cents pages je crois que
c'est le livre
plus
horribles dans le monde
il vous a fallu combien de temps pour
établir ce procès cinq ans quel serait
selon vous le verdict idéal
prison pour toute la vie
lorsque vous comparez ces peines
d'emprisonnement au crime dans ces
hommes sont coupables
ne regrettez vous pas que la peine de
mort étaient des aboli en allemagne non
je suis contre la peine de l'âme de la
mort même devant ces crimes
et aussi je crois que
les crimes
d'acheteurs fritz son si grand et si
horrible qu'elle est en possible
fait de faire un geste hills
pensez vous qu ensuite ces accusés
seront amnistiées
oui pas tout de suite mais peut-être
après un long temps vous le souhaitez
pas maintenant
dans ces conditions je veux dire si l'on
pense déjà à amnistier est-ce que ce
procès bien nécessaire le ministre
estime que ce procès
je crois il est nécessaire pour la
population d'allemagne de connaître à
auschwitz
combien de morts à auschwitz
c'est difficile à dire je crois de 3
millions
pourquoi est-ce difficile à dire
toutes les documents
sont détruits par qui pas un parent
iceman
j'allais oublié de vous dire que la
moitié des accusés y était en liberté
provisoire oui on peut les voir sortir
après chaque audience en voici un
milevskiy un autre brad
un autre stark à ce procès en regardant
les bourreaux nous nous sommes demandé
ce qu'était devenue celle de leurs
victimes qui malgré eux avaient survécu
les anciens déportés ont ils su remonter
l'horreur des camps que leur en reste
ils sont ils aujourd'hui des hommes et
des femmes comme les autres nous en
avons interrogé plusieurs
leurs réponses sont autant de
témoignages
jamais dit vous avez été arrêté le 13
août 1942
car ni té d'être resté à fresnes pendant
14 ou 14 mois et ensuite ensuite
ravensbrück tout le temps tout temps on
n'avait pas changé de gommes j'ai pas
changer de cap pourquoi parce que
j'étais mn et clé allen devait rester
tout le temps ce truc dans un bloc
spécial hélène c'était numéro j'avais
dit un art ou nuit et brouillard
votre mère a été arrêtée en même temps
ma mère était restée à l'état vais vous
donc ma mère dit avec moi je préfère
pour parler
quand vous êtes rentré de déportation
vous pensiez certainement qu'il y avait
une grande différence entre ce qui
n'avait pas été déportés et vous remet
ce temps je pense toujours
comment étiez vous à votre retour
découragé d espérer une option quand
j'étais en manque tout
vraiment j'étais oui vraiment
écoeuré de la vie vraiment et gris
je me souviens d'un sentiment c'est
curieux d'ailleurs toute la période qui
a suivi les morsures de captivité où
j'ai oublié ou les choses donc je me
souviens je les vois comme à travers un
brouillard noir je ne peux pas passer
par exemple passer dans les rues où j'ai
habité dans les années qui ont suivi
immédiatement morte où
rien ne passait dans la rue avant même
d'arriver à la maison où j'ai habité je
sais que je vais y arriver parce que je
somme de quelque chose qui se tord à
l'intérieur de du coeur et pourtant
c'était de terminer
ces types sans que ces moments où j'ai
le plus souffert tout de suite après
tout tu te prix des biens qu'ils avaient
des années déjà
avez vous dû résister à ce moment là l
envie d'en finir un envie de mourir à 8o
suicider eux
je crois qu'il n'y a pas enfin cette
l'idée de la mort comme une chose tu
entends tu
as dû être présente à l'esprit de tous
les déportés ou après leur déportation
et je crois aussi
que au fond
l'idée de la mort vial est d'autant plus
présente qu'on est moins en danger
ça expliquerait peut-être le fait que
certains déportés dont je suis pas mais
je reconnais et bleu danger
parce qu'au fond quand on est en danger
un pouce times vous n'avez plus envie de
mourir après votre retour que pendant
votre déportations pendant la
déportation soviétique après gad
j'en avais une envie on peut pas dire
qu'on en avait envie c'était on vit
dedans
y at il un souvenir que vous avez eu
plus de mal que d'autres vont dire à
vaincre atténuée
je compare cherché à atténuer des
souvenirs hook
parlez-vous spontanément de ce que vous
avez vu et vécu là bas
je déteste parler
vous voulez vous allemand aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je suis tout à fait part je
suis tout à fait pour pour l'europe si
je suis pour le fait que bien entendu il
n'y a pas de responsabilité collective
je suis aussi pour le fait qu'on sache
c'est d'ailleurs pourquoi vous êtes ici
aujourd'hui j'estime qu'on n'a pas le
droit de passer l'épongé on peut pas
dire que deux choses comme celles-là
existé et que c'est comme si ça n'avait
pas existé c'est pas vrai quel sentiment
avez-vous découvert là-bas on avez vous
découvert bon
l'angoissé la peur
la peur
le père
j'ai eu par ailleurs peut-être plus que
là bas
au fond
si vous voulez un sentiment physique de
peur
jaurès a très facilement par exemple où
circulent
beaucoup plus que dans des histoires
comme celles-là comme ravensbrück et au
fond je crois que la peur
est un sentiment qui vous atteint
lorsqu'il n'ya aucune action possible
je n'ai eu peur à ravensbrück que
lorsque il n'était tout à fait
impossible d'intervenir
toutes les fois qu'il y avait la petite
chance d'action l'action efface la peur
qu'est-ce qui remplaçait la peur
angoisse là-bas la pas
non plus te ment pas la bac s qui qu'est
ce qu'ils avaient
la colère
la colère au fond ce qui nous a soutenus
c'était la colère l'indignation
va dire que j'étais un didier
et l'indignation évidemment masse ou du
staff est
est ce que du fait d'avoir été déporté
il y a des choses des gens des
situations qui vous sont insupportables
là je ne peux absolument pas supporté
qu'on humilie quelqu'un de vendre ou
même que je sache que l'umih et je ne
peux absolument pas supporté non plus
enfin souffler je supporte pas je
supporte pas je suis capable de prendre
des risques énormes pour pour l'empêcher
parce que il ya là
je peux pas et je suis pas la seule
alors là je peux vous dire que dans mes
camarades déportés y en a un pourcentage
énorme qui ne supporte pas une chose
comme celle
la réaction est immédiate et intense
vous m'avez dit tout à l'heure que
lorsque vous êtes rentré des baumes
nation vous pensiez que au fond il mieux
valu que personne ne va et bien je suis
têtu d'une pensée qui m'a effleuré
l'esprit et je suis tout à fait contre
bien entendu cette pensée là
disons que j'ai eu pendant des années
l'impression que la souffrance même
injuste
si comme un poison
n'est ce pas on est en pause années de
souffrances on deux de la tête de corps
et d'âme vous comprenez
en un sens où vous sentez guérison
oui je vous dis ryosuke irie
j'en pleurais pas ce mot qu'elle m'en
voyez vous
je dirais peut-être ville
je vais vous avez été arrêté au mois de
mars 1940 prosaïque et l'âge de 15 ans
et demi à monsieur dans quel camp avez
vous été dans le camp de dachau et halak
le camp disciplinaire
quelqu'un qui commande aux calculs même
de dachau avez vous l'impression d'avoir
été modifié pour toute la vie ou avez
vous le sentiment que peu à peu ça
reviendra
depuis combien de temps vous sentez-vous
à peu près comme tout le monde
au
[Musique]
cateau son corps est ce que c'est votre
avis non
je reviens tu te sens quand même temps
comme tout le monde
est ce qu'il ya des choses qui vous sont
devenus insupportables
depuis vous avez été déportés oui par
exemple devoir
de gâcher du 20
juin
sur le chantier par exemple
les ouvriers
énergiquement talent que nous
conte avec 125 g de faim et manger les
trois quarts de ceux de l'eau avec de
l'eau avec un peu de chou et c'est
seulement pour le pain vous avez cette
réaction nouveau nom aussi plein
d'autres choses pour je suis
les algériens portugais
qu'est-ce que vous ne supportez pas mal
ouvert des injustices
vous avez encore des cauchemars
wyss sui se lève d'un bond il les pipis
crime où je
sais pas du tout ce théâtre il est
normalement ça fait peur elle même à la
petite aussi
je toussais secret qui s'est incrusté
pas c'est ça qui je te démange et du
système de santé malgache et est encore
aussi serré vis à vis en france et une
infirmerie
j'ai été mordu par les chiens
j'étais parti
j'étais soleil de l'avion peut pas
mourir
était en quarantaine mais avec ce
secret
souvenait d'avoir d'avoir poussé lorsque
vous étiez au courant
c'est au moment où on était à munich
moment des bombardements
ou les bombes tomber à côté et c'est là
que j'ai reçu un coup de crosse derrière
la tête dans ses écrits lag mort sont
toujours le vôtre
et en même temps quand je me suis
réveillé j'ai vu tous les canadiens ils
étaient tués
c'est toujours le même cri oui c'est
toujours le même cliché mais les moins
forts mais non moins forts qu'eux il
faut maintenant que les premiers temps
pour s'améliorer et familiaux
j'étais moins nerveux le voir
tous les vendredis ou samedis
bons amis dans ce cas vous êtes
polonaise oui et bien tous les deux
françaises pourquoi avez vous choisi
pour vivre un petit village du gard
j'ai pas pour me reposer
vous étiez déportés pendant la guerre
oui
combien de temps 4 ans et 18 jours
pourquoi 18 joue parce que c'est la
dernière qui comme
vous êtes des victimes d'expériences
pseudo scientifique etes-vous obsédé par
vos souvenirs
obsédé c'est peut-être trop désirer mais
je suis poursuivi quand même
non je veux dire est poursuivie en point
de vue physique au point de vue
psychique
enfin je supporte des conséquences si
vous voulez
lors de votre retour vous n'avez jamais
été sur le point de vous suicider non
non pas du tout
j'aime trop la vie quand même dans
l'absolu je trouvais qu'il est bien
gagner j'ai eu un mérite évolué
ça c'est le treuil déjà
y at il des détails de la vie
quotidienne que vous ne pouvez pas
supporter
les détails matériels
oui le manque de place
et aussi quand je vois quelqu'un qui a
faim je descends ça physiquement je peux
pas passer à côté de quelqu'un qui a
faim ce jeu récent ça physiquement ce
sont les restants de déportation
quand vous pensez à votre avenir comment
le voyez-vous
enfin moi je suis pas quelqu'un qui fait
les projets
je sais pas ça me paraît un tout petit
plus je l'étais sa d'été c'est peut-être
un complexe doucement après l'école je
n'aime pas avoir de limites j'étais ce
faire les projets même pour la journée
auguste heure-là quand avez vous été
arrêté le 11 mars 42 ou à paris
que faisiez-vous à cette époque là si
j'avais un handicafé que j'ai toujours
du reste boulevard saint germain
un petit café il s'appelle la reine
blanche pareil connu à saint germain
départ votre vie at-elle été changée et
bien je dois avouer que
la nature m'a doté d'un bon moral et
j'ai fait l'impossible pour oublier ses
progrès pendant ce
temps là vous avez repris votre métier
japonais rien été je suis appris mon
métier j'ai retrouvé tous mes bons amis
qui eux aussi mon idée en oublier tout
cela mais vous avez vous changé et bien
non non très honnêtement non je vais pas
changer je n'ai pas changé je pense être
comme j'étais avant 40 certains anciens
déportés nous ont dit
je ne regrette pas d'avoir été déportés
qu'en pensez vous
eh bien ça dépend à quel point de vue
l'on se place
moi j'avoue que
[Musique]
oui c'est une une expérience et une
expérience pas à tenter mais c'est une
expérience valable pour
pour le restant de ses jours car mon
dieu on ne se connaît pas dans la vie on
ne sait pas ce que l'on vaut surtout
quand on a à peu près tout ce que l'on
désire et quand on est plongé dans
un tel passage est bien
là évidemment chacun suit sa na qu on
est bien on est moche si on est bien
alors là on a l'occasion de le montrer
et si on est un si on a une mauvaise
conscience une mauvaise nature alors là
c'est effroyable c'était effroyable
parce qu'alors lie à un déchaînement
au grand désespoir du reste de ceux qui
qui se trouve l'île qui se révèlent
mauvais car ils s'ignorent et parfois il
signore vous êtes retour d'hernani magne
depuis la libération
non non je ne suis pas revenu avez vous
envie d'y retourner eh bien je voudrais
revoir certains certains coins où nous
avons tellement souffert
ah oui ça mais ça ne plairait pas de
paix des rivages
un pèlerinage
et vous retournez darzins quand vous
avez été prisonnier je suis retourné au
camp d'insert
et j'ai été
désolés de ne rien connaître
je me rappelle se revire j'étais avec le
docteur chabot notamment
et vous j'ai pensé quand même sept mois
de ma vie et dans des conditions
vraiment difficiles
je n'ai même pas su retrouver la place
sur laquelle est implanté le bloc il y
une chapelle dans un coin les villes la
dss ont disparu c'est à peu près nivelé
je n'ai rien trouvé j'en suis sorti avec
une impression
désolé
je me suis dit quand même
ceux qui sont morts ici sont morts deux
fois j'avais les larmes aux yeux
enfin à cinq femmes qui ont été déportée
à ravensbrück nous avons demandé comment
vous êtes vous réadapter à la vie
et adaptation il est très difficile
parce que ma vie a totalement changé
étant données fournies par trop et
j'ai perdu ma raymond fixe il a fallu
changer de vie complètement
je suis sûr que les circonstances du
retour tu as un rôle extrêmement
important dans le set réadaptation bien
sûr quand on la retourne et tous les
siens la réadaptation a compati était
sans nous plus facile
aux six mois oui pour moi je me suis je
naturellement mon fils ait été
complètement détruit par par la guerre
mais par là
l'absence de deux ans mais
je me suis bien adapté à la ville
normalement on travaille ici je
travaille coup je pense que ça m'aide à
oublier en plus jeunes l'amitié de
toutes mes camarades
étaient obligés de travailler oui j'ai
changé de magie a été complètement
changé et qu'elle n'est pas travailler
mais avant la guerre vont travailler
devenant adulte elle une autre situation
que vous alliez vous saviez rien faire
en rentrant j'ai pas bu et il n'en
fallait pas de métier j'ai dû faire un
travail assez vieux pour le moment
pour pouvoir avoir une vie normale après
vous demander ce que vous avez fait j'ai
travaillé dans un hôtel j'ai fait la
cuisine moi tout de même je pense que le
jour j'ai eu mon premier enfant
j'ai senti que
ma vie
pouvoir être normal mais il arrive que
l'horreur comme un revenant dérange à
nouveau la vie
[Musique]
très envoûter par les souvenirs des
souffrances des enfants en déportation
est-ce que je suis ensuite des massacres
d'enfants mangent à
tes camarades
bien de temps en temps en voyant mes
propres enfants je dois faire un effort
pour pour surmonter ce déchirement 7
cette souffrance qui existent encore
vous en avez soigner devait soigner les
nourrissons ses souvenirs pendant tout
l'hiver une raison qui n'essaie de
femmes déportées ans est pratiquement
absent presque tous nos dans les soli
quelques-uns
ont encore quelques cas exceptionnels
est ce que dans les rapports que vous
avez eue avec vos enfants ça a joué
c'est certainement des choses qui a
rendu une adaptation des baies difficile
parce que j'ai eu pendant un certain
temps l'idée ait l'impression que un
enfant ne vivrai pas avec moi j'étais
trop habitués à voir les enfants mourir
avec moi il a fallu que j'ai moi même
quand vous pensez aux accusés du procès
dao suisse quel châtiment souhaitez-vous
pour eux la solution passerait de leur
faire comprendre
or une concentrons jamais dans la
choisit pour moi c'est là
une ancienne déportée française
lorsque je lui ai demandé quel châtiment
elle souhaitait à ses hommes m'a dit le
sol vrai châtiment consisterait à leur
faire comprendre ce qu'ils ont fait mais
je crois que c'est impossible je crois
que c'est une grande idée
j'aime l'idée de cette femme
mais mon expérience dans ce procès ce
qu'elle est accusé
sont encore incapables de connaître
une remorque leur mort
[Musique]